una película definitivamente
destacada sobre el resto es the power of
the dog el poder del perro y sus dos
denominaciones con este western oscuro y
psicológico en flix quizás tiene por fin
la oportunidad de ganar su primer oscar
de la mejor película es que esta edición
de los premios oscar está marcada por la
cantidad de obras nominadas ya
disponibles en las plataformas de vídeo
por demanda la espectacular
superproducción jim del canadiense de
uni binner está en yuma c's tal como el
biopic o rey richard una familia
ganadora donde will smith interpreta al
padre de las hermanas tenistas venus y
serena williams en apple philip los
pueden ver cuidar los sonidos del
silencio que triunfó en el festival de
cine independiente de sundance del año
pasado
netflix encontrarán doble cat no mires
arriba la sátira de adam mckay sobre el
cambio climático y su casting de
estrellas meryl streep leonardo dicaprio
jennifer lawrence por nombrar sólo
algunos encina entre las películas
todavía en las salas y las que pueden
descubrir en la plata de este niño
pueden prepararse de la mejor manera
posible antes de la ceremonia del 27 de
marzo